نحو 600 يوم من الحرب زمن كاف للقول ان
روسيا اخفقت في ادراك نصر حاسم كانت تتطلع
اليه وزمن كاف ايضا للتساؤل ان كان ثمه
تململ داخل المعسكر الحالي في لكيف من طول
امد الحرب يصل الرئيس الاوكراني بولودي
ميرزيلانسكي الى واشنطن طلبا لتعهد من
رئيس بايدن بان يبقي على زخم دعمه العسكري
لكييف لكن زياره زيلينسكي هذه المره وهي
الثانيه له منذ الحرب تختلف عن سابقتها اذ
بات الخصوم الجمهوريون لبايدن يمسكون
بالغالبيه في مجلس النواب وعليه فان
الرئيس الاوكراني لن يحظى هذه المره
باستقبال احتفالي في مبنى الكابيتول كما
جرى في عهد الديمقراطيين
افتتصاعد اصوات داخل الكونجرس يقودها
الجمهوريون لفرض رقابه على الاموال
المخدقه على اوكرانيا يقول زعيم الغالبيه
الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب كيفن مكارثي ان
لديه اسئله يريد طرحها على شان مصير
الاموال الامريكيه والسبيل لتحقيق
الانتصار تقود الولايات المتحده تحالف
رامشتاين الذي يضم 50 دوله بمثاق ينص على
الدعم العسكري لا محدود لاوكرانيا في
مواجهه روسيا منذ الرابع والعشرين من
يناير 2022 وحتى يونيو الماضي تتجاوز
التقديرات بالدعم الغربي لكييف 166 مليار
دولار
48% من هذا الدعم كان لاغراض عسكريه على
علاقه بميدان الحرب اما الباقي فكان دعما
ماليا لحكومه زيلانسكي ومساعدات انسانيه
80 مليار دولار هي قيمه الدعم العسكري
الغربي من الخوذ والدروع الواقيه من
الرصاص الى انظمه الدفاع الصاروخي
والدبابات وتجري الاستعدادات لتزويد كييف
بمقاتلات اف 16
تصدرت اداره الرئيس جو بايدن الداعمين اذ
قدمت الولايات المتحده وحدها 71 مليار
دولار يليها الاتحاد الاوروبي بخمسه
وثلاثين مليار دولار تاتي بريطانيا ثالثا
اذ قارب ما قدمته لاوكرانيا منذ بدء الحرب
11 مليار دولار اما المانيا التي عرضت في
البدايه المساهمه باسلحه ثقيله لكنها
استسلمت في النهايه لضغط من حلفائها فقارب
دعمها 11 مليار دولار من بينها نحو 8
مليارات لاغراض عسكريه منذ بدء الحرب قادت
بولندا الجار الاوروبي الاقرب لاوكرانيا
ما وصف بمعسكر الصقور الداعم لكييف لكنها
اليوم تتراجع على نحو لافت خطوه الى
الوراء يقول رئيس الوزراء البولندي
ماتواشكي ان بولندا توقفت عن تسليح
اوكرانيا وانها تركز فقط على تعزيز قوتها
الدفاعيه والواضح ان رئيس الوزراء
البولندي بموقفه هذا انما يوازن ما بين
استحقاقات انتخابات تستعد لها البلاد
الشهر المقبل وبين تعهدات بولندا العضو في
الاتحاد الاوروبي والنيتو واكثر المتخوفين
من ان تتجاوز طموحات روسيا اوكرانيا الى
جيرانها